STEVE: WELCOME BACK.
AS TENSIONS RISE BETWEEN THE
UNITED STATES AND RUSSIA,
OVER UKRAINE, VLADIMIR PUTIN IS
LAYING THE BLAME ON THE WEST,
CLAIMING HE FEARS NATO EXPANSION
INTO THE REGION.
HE ALSO IS CLAIMING HE IS NOT
LOOKING FOR A FIGHT, SAYING THIS
WEEK, "ARM CONFLICTS AND
BLOOD SHED ARE ABSOLUTELY NOT
SOMETHING WE WOULD CHOOSE."
HERE WITH REACTION IS FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR AND FORMER SECRETARY
OF STATE, MIKE POMPEO.
MR.  POMPEO, GOOD MORNING TO YOU
AND HAPPY CHRISTMAS EVE.
>> THANK YOU, HAPPY CHRISTMAS
EVE TO YOU, STEVE IT’S GREAT TO
BE WITH YOU THIS MORNING.
STEVE: WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF MR.
PUTIN SAYING YEAH, DON’T
BLAME US, BLAME THE WEST.
HE WAS ALSO ASKED, WILL YOU
GUARANTEE YOU WON’T INVADE
UKRAINE AND HE GOES UM, NO.
>> WELL, VLADIMIR PUTIN HAS
BEEN ON THE STAGE FOR AN AWFULLY
LONG TIME.
HE KNOWS FULL
WELL THAT LATVIA ISN’T GOING TO
INVADE RUSSIA.
HE KNOWS THIS , IT’S VICTIM
IZATION TO ASSERT SOMEHOW
HE FEELS THREATENED FROM THOSE
COUNTRIES FOR AN INVASION.
HE’S THE ONE THAT RAISED THE
TENSION, NOT FAULT-WISE WITH
HIM BUT THERE’S FAULT IN THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION TOO
WHEN PUTIN SAW WHAT HAPPENED IN
AFGHANISTAN, THE TERRIBLE
TRAGEDY OF 13 AMERICANS BEING
KILLED AND REAL WEAKNESS BEING
SHOWN WHEN WE GAVE HIM THE
OPPORTUNITY TO FINISH HIS
PIPELINE AND HAVE ENERGY CONTROL
OVER GERMANY, HE SAW AMERICAN
WEAKNESS AND SO I THINK WHAT
YOU’VE SEEN OVER THESE PAST DAYS
AND WEEKS IS HIM BUILDING AND
PUTTING PRESSURE ON THE
AMERICANS LOOKING FOR
CONCESSIONS TRYING TO
ACHIEVE SOMETHING THROUGH
THREATS AND COERCION THAT HE
DOESN’T WANT TO DO MILITARILY
BUT HE’S PERFECTLY PREPARED TO
PUSH THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION TO
THE EDGE TO SEE IF HE CAN’T GET
WHAT HE WOULD REALLY LIKE.
STEVE: AND YOU KNOW, MR.
SECRETARY, WHEN THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES HAD A VIRTUAL SUMMIT WITH
MR. PUTIN A COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO,
HE SAID JOE BIDEN SAID IF YOU
INVADE THERE ARE GOING TO BE
HEAVY ECONOMIC SANCTIONS.
IS THAT BIG ENOUGH?
AND HE SAID FOR THE MOST PART
THE MILITARY ARE HARDWARE OFF
THE TABLE.
IS THAT ENOUGH OF A BIG STICK?
>> YOU KNOW, STEVE, WE FORGET
IN JUST THIS YEAR ITS BEEN A
LONG YEAR THE FIRST 11 MONTHS
NOW THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
WE FORGET, IT WAS RUSSIA THAT
SHUTDOWN A PIPELINE INSIDE THE
UNITED STATES CLOSING OFF
GASOLINE TO THE UNITED STATES
FOR DAYS, AND PRESIDENT BIDEN
SAID DON’T DO THAT AGAIN.
IT TURNED OUT TO BE A PRETTY
IDLE THREAT THERE WERE NO REAL
COSTS IMPOSED THAT WE’RE AWARE
OF SO I SUSPECT PUTIN TAKES
THOSE THREATS WITH A GRAIN OF
SALT.
IT’S GOING TO TAKE A DEMONSTRAT
ED RESULT NOT JUST
WORDS BUT DEEDS AND PREPAREDNESS
AND A DEMONSTRATION OF
PREPAREDNESS FROM THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION TO STOP PUTIN
FROM ACTING IN THIS COERCIVE WAY
STEVE: SURE.
I REMEMBER YOU FROM WHEN YOU
WERE OUR KANSAS CONGRESSMAN.
WHAT SORT OF TRADITIONS, FAMILY
KANSAS TRADITIONS DID YOU HAVE
AT CHRISTMASTIME, MR. SECRETARY?
>> YOU KNOW, STEVE, WE HAD A
COUPLE.
ONE OF MY FAVORITES WAS EVERY
YEAR OUR FAMILY WOULD GATHER
TOGETHER AND MAKE THIS SECRET
POMPEO FUDGE RECIPE,
CAME FROM MY MOM’S SIDE OF THE
FAMILY, HER MOTHER, GRACE ME
RCER’S RECIPE AND I
RELEASED IT WHEN I WAS A
DIRECTOR, WE THOUGHT IT BE FUN
TO TAKE A SECRET RECIPE AND
RELEASE IT.
MOM WAS CLEARLY IN CHARGE, DAD
AND I AND MY BROTHER AND SISTER
WERE THE LABOR BUT IT WAS ALWAYS
GOOD.
WE WOULD MAKE FUDGE AND
DISTRIBUTE IT TO PEOPLE IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD AND TEACHERS
AND THE LIKE.
THE KINDS OF THINGS FAMILIES DO
TOGETHER AND NOW MY WIFE SUSAN
AND SON NICK AND HIS FIANCEE
RACHEL WILL REPEAT THAT NOW THIS
YEAR AND IT’S A LOT OF FUN
JUST TO GATHER AROUND IN THE
KITCHEN TO TALK ABOUT TO
WORK A LITTLE BIT AND TO DO A
GOOD TURN FOR FRIENDS AND PEOPLE
WE LOVE.
STEVE: WELL THAT’S GREAT.
OBVIOUSLY THE FUDGE RECIPE HAS
BEEN DECLASSIFIED BECAUSE WE
JUST PUT IT ON TV.
YOU KNOW, ONE OF THE DOOCY
FAMILY TRADITIONS, I WOULD
ALWAYS TAKE THE CHILDREN RUNNING
DOWN THE STAIRS AND I SHOWED A
COUPLE OF DAYS AGO.
THE OTHER THING WE DO EVERY
CHRISTMAS EVE AND WE’LL DO IT
TONIGHT, OUR TOWN HAS A SING-
ALONG, WHERE EVERYBODY
GATHERS AND WE SING ACTUAL
CHRISTMAS CAROLS, AND I THINK
WE’VE GOT SOME PICTURES OF IT
WHERE THE KIDS DO THE SINGING,
THEY HANDOUT THE SHEET MUSIC,
AND THERE YOU CAN SEE RIGHT
THERE.
IT’S DARK.
PETER DOOCY HAS THE FLASHLIGHT
AND HE’S THE TOWNS DEEPEST VOICE
WITH THE BEST BARITONE AS THEY
RECREATE 12 DAYS OF CHRISTMAS.
VERY NICE.
ANYWAY, AND THERE WE ARE.
MIKE POMPEO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> I’D KILL YOUR RATINGS THIS
MORNING, STEVE.
STEVE: [LAUGHTER]
OH, CHRISTMAS.
ANYTHING GOES.
MR. POMPEO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR JOINING US AND MERRY
CHRISTMAS.
>> THANK YOU, MERRY CHRISTMAS
TO YOU ALL AS WELL.
STEVE: I TELL YOU WHAT, MR.
POMPEO, COULD WE PUT THAT
RECIPE ON FOX & FRIENDS SO WE
COULD SHARE IT WITH EVERYBODY?
>> YEAH, THAT BE AWESOME, STEVE
I WOULD LOVE THAT.
SUSAN AND MY MOTHER WHOSE PASSED
AWAY NOW WOULD LOVE THAT AS WELL
STEVE: OKAY.
SO FOLKS, GIVE US A HALF AN HOUR
AND WE WILL GET A LINK TO THE
FAMILY SECRET FUDGE RECIPE.
ALL RIGHT, MIKE, THANK YOU VERY